we have something a little bit different
tonight and I hope you'll be as pleased
as I am we're about to embark on summer
movie season and summer movie season
means superheroes Iron Man superman you
name it and they're all going to be on
the screen soon it's not often though
that you get a chance to meet and
celebrate a real hero and we have one
with us tonight I hope you'll welcome
for a brief introduction from mrs.
Jackie Robinson Rachel Robinson
thank thank you so much I'm just so
delighted that the Academy is supporting
the film and I must tell you that I'm
thrilled by the film waited 30 years to
have it made and we've had some false
starts but we've got a real great
picture I think and this weekend's
results that the theaters has encouraged
us a lot to believe that this film is
going to be seen by many I'm
particularly interested in having it
children and young people see it because
I think it's not only educational but
it's very inspiring and they will get a
sense of what the challenges are in life
and how to turn an obstacle into a
challenge and do something about it so I
hope you'll enjoy the film and see that
all your children and young people
follow behind you
thank you